listen i think one of the most important
things going on right now
is dealing with the opioid epidemic i
think that it is a massive problem that
is
under even though we talk about it it's
still underserved
you know it's still a huge issue uh you
have a
movie coming out called dreamland which
deals with that head-on
um what was it about that project that
said i want to do this
and and talk a little bit about it well
you know nick jarecki who directed it
he he's a friend of mine we've known
each other for a long time and he came
to me he said hey man listen i've
i'm i've got this movie uh it's about
the opioid crisis
and i've i've almost lost multiple
friends to
opioid addictions whether it be you know
heroin or pills
or a mixture of both um and it
it is it is a massive epidemic that we
are dealing with in america that
because pharmaceutical medications make
so much money
not only for the pharmaceutical
companies but also for
lobbyists also for politicians also for
everyone
uh we turn a blind eye to this i mean
the amount of people who die from opioid
addictions
in america is staggering um and also i
read the script and i thought this is
really good and this is really
interesting and it's really highlighting
that this doesn't just affect
you know this affects everyone there's
there's no one
safe from opioid addiction especially in
america where they're so quick to
prescribe pills and
and also with how easy it is and also
with with fentanyl the fact that we've
invented this [ __ ]
poison called fentanyl that's like a
hundred times stronger than morphine
and just the littlest tiny sprinkle of
it and you'll overdose and
you know and this the movie is about a
drug ring in canada
that is getting the uh ingredients for
fentanyl sent in from china
processing it and then shipping the
pills down into america and
this is what's happening this happens
all the time you know i mean
so um we wanted to make a film about it
and show the sort of like the stark
reality